in this video i'm going to show you the
handful of abnormal
routines that i do that people have
laughed at me for
but that i believe will serve you
first off right off the bat i'm not the
type of person who does
you know cold showers and like light
stuff and
red saunas and you know the
orange glasses and the finger toe shoes
and the biohacking and like all that
stuff i don't i don't really
subscribe to that kind of methodology i
would say that most of the things that
i've seen that have been quote
productivity hacks
really become to borrow something from
my wife uh procrastination hacks it's
people who love making
spending all their time making lists and
not really doing and so
i'm i don't do a lot of things on a
regular basis so i don't have a
tremendously complex routine and that is
i think because
i would rather spend my time working
i'll give you a handful of things that
have served me well
the first is that for i would say the
first and this is where i think is more
valuable to people who are coming up
for the first probably eight years of my
business career i woke up around four
o'clock in the morning just about every
day
and part of that came because i started
in the fitness industry and i was doing
that anyways
but also because i didn't have to talk
to anyone until about 10 a.m
and so that gave me about six hours of
uninterrupted work time that i could
really move projects forward
and so yes that means the first thing i
did every morning was i would wake up
and i would start working
and i think that the morning really
actually starts the night before and so
this is something i don't know if it's
talked about as much
but for me i can't it's it's more
difficult for me to go to sleep
until i have thought about what i'm
going to do the next day so i feel like
i have to clear my mental kind of like
bandwidth and say all right what are the
few things i'm going to focus on
tomorrow
and i've never really given myself more
than three things to do and so it's
usually one to three things people like
was it two or is it three or is it one
i don't really believe in making rules
around that stuff so
if i'm just gonna be editing my book
tomorrow then that might be the only
thing i have
if i have a couple of things that are
gonna take a little bit of time that i
might have three things on the calendar
right
and that's about it right and so the
first kind of habit around this is that
i plan the night before
i know what i'm going to do the moment i
wake up and then upon waking up
i pretty much just start getting to work
and i have my first
four six hours of the day dedicated to
moving those things forward
and for a lot of people that's hard but
i think that so is being successful and
you just have to pick what kind of hard
you want being broke is hard so as being
successful is just one of them
you know might get you close to your
goals so that's the first kind of habit
that i would say that i do
that's maybe atypical is that i don't
have some crazy routine in the morning
besides
i drink a cup of coffee and that's about
it the second thing
is i try and decrease the amount of
decisions that i have to make throughout
the day and so for me
i think decisions that we make over and
over and over again i think are wasted
ones especially if they're
the outcome is pretty much moot and so
one of those things is like food
and so i eat the same thing every day
for breakfast lunch and dinner and um
that may sound crazy to you but uh for
me i like what i have for breakfast
lunch and dinner and so i look forward
to it every day and
i don't really have any stress that goes
around that beyond that
uh this is very very small but uh if
you've acquired a lot of belongings over
your you know time period
trinkets and things like that i think
you gain a tremendous amount of
attention
from getting rid of those things which
is probably why if you've ever like
cleaned out your garage or cleaned out a
storage closet you
feel better it's like ah all these like
little attention that that was just like
left there and every time i walked by i
was like i should do something about
that
well try and clear as many of those
things as you can so that you have as
much of that bandwidth back
and i think that that kind of manifests
itself in just better higher quality
decisions the third thing
that i'll say that i would do is that's
somewhat different so the first being uh
the night before early morning wake up
no real routine there besides just get
to work
and the second being like i ate the same
things every day the third piece
is kind of the the nighttime side of it
which is
i think it's more important to have a
bedtime than it is to have a wake-up
time
and so you might you know hear me say
yes i wake up at 4 a.m
but that might mean that it's 4 45 some
days it might mean it's 3 10 some days
it might mean it's even 5 30 some days
i'm more inclined to just go to sleep
earlier
and wake up when i wake up than trying
to
you know get myself out of bed when i'm
exhausted
and from all the very very wealthy
people that i i know
they value the quality of sleep that
they have not that they're obsessed with
it because i know that i can work on
four hours of sleep for a very long
period of time
but i make better high quality decisions
uh when i am well rested
and so the third kind of habit around
that is set an alarm for your bedtime
rather than your wake up time it's a
tiny little hack and i think it'll it'll
do you a lot of good
um and so for me you might think wow
that's
not a lot of routines and i think that
there's something to that i
when i hear about someone who says like
ah unless i you know
do a polar plunge and i and i walk
outside barefoot and i have all these
things that happen
i don't think that i to me that sounds
like you're not resilient at all and
that you can't handle stress at all
i want to be able to be resilient so
that no matter what condition i'm in i'm
adaptable and i can
survive and hopefully thrive and so if i
it's me against somebody who needs to
have you know their
that all of their pens in order and all
of their you know their their 20 minutes
of journaling in the morning and then
they have to read their book and then
after that they have to do their
their their out loud ohms and they have
to do this whole song and dance what
ends up happening it starts creating
superstition
around how you work and that's bad
because now you become reliant on that
action in order to just be functional
not above functional
because anything that gives you like a
short-term boost oftentimes just becomes
a crutch
over time and so i'm very very sensitive
to superstitions and having crutches
because i would rather just say hey i
can wake up
i can drink a cup of coffee and i can
get to work and i think that a lot of
times people who look into all these
productivity hacks look into all these
routines look into all this stuff
many times use that as a crutch to lean
on to feel productive
rather than actually getting work done
and so
big picture those are the things that
have actually yielded me
disproportionate returns i've tried a
lot of that stuff i've tried the
gratitude journals i've tried the you
know saying things out loud the
affirmations i've tried
all of these different things and the
things that stuck were the things that
were simple
and i think that if you look at lots of
successful people
the the sleeping hours that they keep
are wildly different there's some people
who work do their best work between 10 8
you know 10 p.m and 4 a.m
and they work night outs i've got a
friend of mine who's a billionaire who
does that and that's he's like
alex i can't wake up and do work any
time before 10 a.m and i'm like that's
cool like that's how he does it and so i
think it's more important to figure out
what sleeping schedule do i get the best
work done in
and when can i allocate time that is
just my time to think and as
entrepreneurs like the higher up we go
to more about the decisions
we make rather than the actions we take
and that's something that i've stuck
with and so as always
it's here alex ramos the owner of jim
launch prestige labs and alan we've done
you know
120 plus million we're on pace for over
85 million this year
i have nothing to sell you i make these
videos because i hope that someone uh
learns from some of the lessons and
doesn't have to
fall for the the many traps along the
way of uh the productivity hacks and the
biohacking and all this craziness
that can just get in the way of just get
it done do the boring work and
you'll see the results i'll see on the
other side